in 1879 amateur archaeologist Marcellino
sans de south Ola and his young daughter
Maria explored a dark cave in northern
Spain when Maria wandered off by herself
she made an amazing discovery they were
standing inside a site of ancient art
the walls and roofs decorated with
prehistoric paintings and engravings
ranging from 19 to 35 thousand years old
similar marks of our ancestors have been
preserved in caves all over the world
the oldest we found were made up to
40,000 years ago what do these images
tell us about the ancient human mind and
the lives of their creators these early
artists mixed mineral clay charcoal and
ochre with Spitz or animal fat to create
paint they drew with their hands and
tools like pads of moss twigs bones and
hair in many instances their images
follow the contours of the cave to
create depth and sink the most common
depictions are of geometric shapes
followed by large mammals like bison
horses mammoths deer and boar human
figures appear rarely as well as
occasional entrance some have theorized
that these artworks are the creation of
hunters or of holy men in trance lengthy
and we found examples created by men
women and even children and why did they
create this art perhaps they were
documenting what they knew about the
natural world like modern scientists or
marking their tribal territory
maybe the images were the culmination of
sacred hunting rituals or spiritual
journeys or could they be art for art
things the sheer joy and fulfillment of
creation as with many unsolved mysteries
of the ancient world we may never know
for sure
barring the invention of a crime machine
but while we answer selenium is elusive
these images are our earliest proof of
human communication testifying to the
human capacity for creativity thousands
of years before writing they are a
distinct visual language that imagines
the world outside the self just like
modern art forms from Ruffini and
painting to animated virtual reality
cave
you